[Music]
[Applause]
Jean-Jacques Taylor our good buddy is
the author of Coach Prime Dion Sanders
and the making of men former Dallas
Morning News sports columnist how did
this uh idea for a book with Dion come
about
actually man it's uh it came I did a
cover story for Sports Illustrated last
year on Dion and Travis Hunter and
shador Sanders and literally two days
after I did that cover story of the
people from harpercollins called and
said we've been wanting to write a DIY
Book for a year we think you're the guy
based on what we read in sports
illustrator would you do it
and I said uh hell yeah I do I just uh I
got to check with Dion though so I
called Dion actually I texted him I said
hey give me a call when you get a second
he hit me back a couple minutes later
and I said hey man I got this
opportunity what do you think and he
said uh I got you whatever you need you
got it uh go sign the contract and so I
did and uh the beauty of it DP
is that to this day Dion never asked me
who I was talking to what I was writing
about what I was what angles I was
taking hey he just never said anything
he said you got to run into place you
can do whatever you want I trust you to
tell the story in an honest uh in an
honest way
oh man that's you know having total
autonomy uh Dion trusted you that much
now did you find out anything that Dion
would have been upset about or was upset
about
no because Dion is really an honest dude
and so here's the one thing I told him
um this is probably three quarters
through the season I win his office and
I said duh let me tell you something you
didn't gave me full access to the
program I can go wherever I want to talk
to anybody want to sit in on any meeting
I want to
and there's still a hundred things going
on I have no idea about and he started
laughing he goes this is what the head
coach is all about now I'm serious it's
amazing all of the stuff that goes on
that I would find out two or three weeks
later and it's not that people were
keeping secrets it's just that much goes
on in the program when you got 115
players in the program and coaches and
their families and it's uh it's amazing
because you know man I've been covering
the Cowboys since 1995. I've been around
football I know football but I ain't
never been up close in a program or on a
team where you really see the inside of
how it goes down and so even somebody
who's been around the football as much
as me it was fascinating and it was a
great time I thought Florida State
should have reached out and brought Dion
in uh I was told that Dion was really
trying to get a job I mean really had to
go out there and sell himself to try to
have somebody take a chance on him
Jackson State obviously did but he was
still looking to get one of these jobs
maybe in the you know Dallas area uh in
the state of Texas why were schools
hesitant do you feel with Dion and
bringing him in to run a program
well I think it's this number one even
though he's been successful coaching
high school we all know there's a jump
from a high school program to a college
program so that's number one
as a program you got to be bold to hire
somebody like Dina because he's not
coming in as an assistant he's coming in
as the guy
but he doesn't have a track record as a
college coach so I understand why you
would not want to make that move
um but and the other thing man is even
now that he is a college coach Prime is
not for everybody like he can't work for
everybody nor does everybody want him to
work because he does things his way
he proved he believes in his way he
knows his way works and if you let him
do his thing it's all good
um if you start interfering and saying
hey you can't do this or hey you can't
do that then you're gonna have a problem
because the one weakness he has we
talked about this many times the man has
no patience
he says Hey DP I need this done tomorrow
he wants it done tomorrow not a week
from now they don't want to cut through
no red tape he wants it done now and as
an athletic director if you're not ready
to work like that then you're gonna have
a problem with it
uh is he a coach is he the head coach or
is he the Ambassador is he you know like
Bobby Bowden was at Florida State there
for a while it felt like and and this
isn't a disservice to Dion Because I
know he's brought in some really good
football coaches but I don't know what
how would you describe Dion in his role
at Colorado
oh he's a coach for real now what he
does is number one he creates culture
two he says ADP what and this one this
is really highly worse a DP what do you
need to be successful as a defensive
line coach
you tell me what do you need and
whatever you tell them you need
he goes and gets it for you I need two I
need two uh nose tackles and I need
three legitimate pass rushes the best we
can get okay go get it go recruit
whatever you want
because they don't have a system where
it's like here's a recruiting board they
say DP go get the players you like I'll
look at them I'll make sure they can
play what else do you need
okay I got everything I need coach all
right now he holds you then accountable
to the utmost to get it done and uh when
I say accountable is that what coach
told me he said I have never felt so bad
getting yelled at from a man who didn't
cuss at me because he brings it man and
what he does is and this is this is a
very nuanced statement
um he pulls people to Greatness like you
can push people and say come on man we
need this we need this what he does is
he sets an incredibly high standard and
then he pulls you to that standard by
demanding that you do this and you do
this and you do this because if you do
these things you will then reach that
standard that I think is acceptable for
us Jean-Jacques Taylor the author of
Coach Prime Deion Sanders uh it comes
out on October 10th and it's a Insider
account unprecedented access with Dion
and his players uh Jean-Jacques covered
the Cowboys for uh quite some time at
the Dallas Morning News what did you
make a Dion calling out edwarder during
that post-game press conference now I've
not talked to him about this but this is
my perception of it like we all all of
us know where there's a TV guy he was
actually my first partner in the Cowboys
how about that and so um obviously he
didn't write anything I took it more as
that was a face that was familiar to him
and that was a situation where he's like
this is a perfect foil for what I'm
trying to do which is say I need some
foil to get out my message of y'all
didn't believe in me oh there's a
familiar face but sucks for you buddy
it's for my foil today that's what I
think it was
did you know the story about tank
Johnson threatening edwardor's life and
Ed bought a gun
no he had told me the story because he
had written something about Terrell
Owens and being toxic and that Romo and
you know Whitton and some of these guys
wanted wanted him you know gone tank
Johnson walks up to Edward and says
where do you live
and he was threatening to kill him Ed
went out and got a gun
that's uh you know obviously I was there
when they were taking jobs on team I
can't believe
I mean we were all writing the T.O was
toxic in a way so I don't know why words
um I was telling somebody yesterday
about the time Charles Haley almost
killed me and
[Music]
um
I took some responsibility for it
because well tell me his story here I
believe it was 1995. all right and this
is when you had the this is when I love
being a
first year because I work people uh now
everything is you can only talk right
now so it is what it is so I was in the
locker room it was just me and Nate
Newton because it was like 5 30 in the
afternoon I was just working and he's
showing me some blocking techniques and
explaining some stuff to me and Charles
Haley comes in now Charles Haley is
forever saying is up it's forever
messing with people in in a good natured
way sometimes sometimes not well he said
something to me from across the locker
room and me at that time of 27 I'm full
of uh you know what in vinegar and I
said something back to him because at
the time his daughter was sick and I was
I basically said the only reason you've
been cool lately is you want some media
attention for your daughter oh oh I said
I crossed the line oh
and at that point he looked at me
and started walking across the locker
room and Nate was like duh you need to
go now and I took one look at Charles
and I was like dog you right
I didn't Sprint but I had to quick walk
on and I was gone and uh you know
nothing else came of it but had he
gotten over there I'd have had a problem
yeah just so you know I saw him at the
the star yesterday and he gave me five
and hit me in the shoulder so he hadn't
changed much
do you have a prediction on the Cowboys
this year
um I think they got a really good team
man they got a really hard schedule
because I I think they played at AFC
East this year in those three you know
even the Patriots though they're down so
I think they're going 11-5 well 11 and
six now
um so they may lose a little bit more
but that defense is terrific and I think
I feel dumb but I think this is the year
the embarrassing 28 year drought is and
they get to the NFC Championship Game
wow okay um all right that's what I
think I don't think they get to the
Super Bowl but I think you can see them
in the FC championship game because I
think it's them Philly in San Francisco
and I think this is uh the year that
they take one more step forward
yeah
uh you might as well go all the way with
it Jean-Jacques and they're going to win
the Super Bowl
no I can't go there man can't go there I
mean this is the team of discipline
7 14 16. that's what that's why we had
this drought because those were the
years they were poised to get to the
Super Bowl and didn't make it happen so
I can't put them there
you had to be thrilled with that opening
week win by Diono you're writing a book
about Dion and Dion now is the talk of
college football how how exciting was
that I don't know if you were nervous
watching it but you know you want that
you want Dion to be recognized you know
by everybody as a good college coach and
you got that win against TCU
here's what happened man I'm watching
obviously I met the game and you all
know this how's it start you get three
and up okay the defense is suspect three
and that I'm going okay they go right
down the field and score I go okay and
then TCU does what it does and they look
like they're about to score and they
throw that pick in the end zone I go oh
this is exactly how upsets happen
and here's for me the key moment was
into the second quarter uh Dylan Edwards
fumbled I think TCU tied the game up and
right then the bug the the Buffalo still
went down and got a field goal and I go
to myself but let's see what happens at
the start of third quarter because they
get the ball they score on a 75-yard
screen pass and at that point I go on
Twitter I think it doesn't matter
whether they win or lose the players
will now will believe the recruits will
believe they'll be able to recruit and I
think it'll be a close game but when
they got the win man I started texting
those coaches going dude I can't believe
y'all pulled this off because I was in
Boulder last week and all y'all told me
was our lines uh I don't know what we're
gonna get man we're just gonna go out
there and play hard and see what happens
and so yeah I ain't gonna lie to you
yeah everybody wants a great story when
you're writing the book and what
Colorado's done what Dion's done and Dan
is a good dude man you know everybody
sees the Flash and Pomp and Circumstance
but he's a really quiet guy but away
from the cameras here's that I'll tell
you this real quick DP the reason me and
Dion got to be cool is this he was
leading the league in punt returns in
like 96 or 97. and I kind of figured him
out uh he was only coming in the locker
room every now and then and I walked
over to him I said hey man you're
leading the league of punt returns let
me do a piece on all the guys blocking
for you because I knew he didn't like to
talk about himself
when asked now he'll talk about himself
but when you start asking about him he
likes really to defer attention to
everybody else and he said oh okay I got
you and we sat down and talked
and he gave me some great stuff and I
came back a couple days later with the
story and I literally just handed it to
him and said here's what I wrote I
turned around and left and whenever he
saw me the next time he said hey that
was a good article I got you whenever
you need me
and that's kind of how our relationship
started then and even after he stopped
playing we just always kind of stayed in
touch my son went to his football camp a
couple times and the thing about
Colorado is I mean even Jackson state is
I knew several of the coaches on the
team because I had been around his youth
program a little bit uh and so even
though I knew him I was also familiar
with probably half of his staff and so
you know we just had kind of an ongoing
relationship over the years and he's a
good dude
good luck with the book great to catch
up with you again thank you hey I
appreciate you guys man thanks Steve
Jean-Jacques Taylor coach Prime Dion
Sanders in the making of men and uh Sean
Jacques uh down through the years
contributor to this show with uh
covering the Cowboys